when you think of ringed planets well
you probably assume there's only one of
them in our solar system Saturn
but what if I told you that there are
three other planets similar to Saturn
yeah it's true Jupiter Uranus and
Neptune all have their own sets of rings
that most people don't know about them
because they're much thinner and pretty
much invisible from Earth
we only learned about them when Voyager
1 and Voyager 2 flew past them in the
1970s and 80s
some scientists even think that Earth
had rings at some point in its existence
four and a half billion years ago when a
planet the size of Mars smashed into our
young rock it ejected so much debris
that it likely briefly formed a small
ring around Earth
despite their unimaginably massive
gravitational pull black holes don't go
around sucking in everything in their
way
it just doesn't work like that black
holes are more like sinkholes
if you were to get too close to one
you'd get spaghettified and lost to the
Blackness of this monstrosity but if
you're far enough away from it you'd be
safe
even if our sun was replaced in the
middle of our solar system by a black
hole with similar mass
all the planets would just orbit like
nothing happened
things would get pretty dark though
now speaking of Darkness the moon
doesn't have a dark side
our planetary partner gets hit by the
sunlight all around
the reason why you don't see the other
side of the moon is because it's always
facing away from us yeah our moon
rotates on its axis at the same rate it
orbits Earth making it what's called
tidally locked to our planet
if a large asteroid is on a deadly
Collision Course with Earth the best
thing to do is to Nuke it
oh sorry wait I've actually got that
wrong
do not nuke asteroids that are about to
collide with us the reason why well
because the nuclear explosion will
shatter the asteroid into millions of
smaller pieces yeah the pieces that
would still be headed for impact with us
instead of dealing with just one giant
asteroid we'd have to deal with multiple
impacts and it would make our evacuation
really difficult or straight up
impossible
now you still can use a nuke to prevent
an asteroid Collision but you don't even
have to strike the space Rock we just
set off a nuke near the asteroid
emphasis on near
then the force from the blast would
nudge it off course that would keep our
planet safe
hopefully
you know nuking the asteroid off course
isn't the only good thing you can do for
our planet sometimes it's simpler than
that like making sure our air and water
are clean unfortunately just the other
week the Supreme Court cut back the
Environmental Protection agency's
authority to regulate water pollution
and that's bad news over the past 50
years the EPA reduced six of the most
common air pollutants by 78 percent and
significantly improved air quality their
work has saved countless ecosystems and
restricting the epa's ability to control
water and air pollution is going to have
serious consequences in the future but
you know what together we can put people
ahead of corporate profits and protect
our environment
speak out vote and make sure your
representatives know how vital the epa's
work is to you we only have one chance
on this planet
standing on Earth at night you can see
thousands of stars but the view from the
Moon is actually quite boring
yeah astronauts who traveled to the Moon
reported that stars aren't easily
visible from there because our moon is
super reflective it really cranks up the
brightness making it harder to see out
to the Stars it's kind of like
stargazing in a city with a lot of light
pollution not fun
you'd need to travel further into space
to get some better views
traveling in space won't make you taller
though it's true that astronauts can
grow up to five centimeters in space
well that's because the Earth's gravity
doesn't weigh them down and the
vertebrae in their spines are able to
expand a bit but this effect is only
temporary as soon as you return to Earth
you get back to your regular height
yeah thanks gravity
and space travel doesn't make you age
slower either not really
Albert Einstein theorized that time
would pass slower for someone traveling
at high speeds versus for someone
stationary this is called time dilation
and while it's true you'd have to travel
incredibly fast to achieve this de-aging
effect like almost speed of light fast
yeah with our current space traveling
technology the difference in time is so
minimal that it's not even worth
calculating
if you thought crying in space was
impossible well first why and second
you're wrong it's just different
without gravity to pull your tears down
they don't trickle down your face like
they do here on Earth the tears just
stick to your eyes and form a sort of
watery blob
they might even cover your eyes if you
cry a lot so while you can totally cry
in space it's probably best that you
don't
not great for visibility
hey Martian dust storms are a real
headache the dust particles are so fine
that they can get anywhere and these
dust storms can last for months but they
can't physically damage any equipment
that we leave on the red planet
the thing is is that the Martian
atmosphere is super thin just about one
percent of the atmosphere we have on
Earth so even when these dust particles
Zoom around at about 100 kilometers per
hour
they can't pack a big punch without the
help of air
but what they can do is cover our solar
panels and put our Rovers into power
saving hibernation
oh and I wouldn't inhale this dust
either who knows what this fine powder
could do to your lungs long term
twinkle twinkle little star how I wonder
what you are up above the world so high
this song is a big fat lie
yeah despite the famous children's song
Stars don't twinkle the flickering is
Just an Illusion their light is actually
very steady
stars appear to twinkle due to the gas
molecules that make up our atmosphere
they deflect some of the light from
Stars making them appear as if they're
shimmering
asteroid belts are typically depicted as
minefields of floating rocks spaceships
have to weave in and out of the
asteroids in a life or death situation
but in reality our asteroid belts are
nothing like what you see in the movies
asteroids aren't that close together in
fact they're extremely far apart
for example in the asteroid belt between
Jupiter and Mars each of the asteroids
is several million kilometers away from
their nearest neighbor
and the chances of a collision are about
one in one billion
so while Khan Chewie and Leia had you on
the edge of your seat and The Empire
Strikes Back asteroid Fields like that
are far from reality
the Great Wall of China is known to be
the only man-made object that's visible
from space
but this is entirely false
yeah sure maybe you could see it with a
camera and a zoom lens but it's almost
invisible to the naked eye
add 5 to 10 meters wide the wall is way
too thin to be seen from space however
you can still see plenty of other
man-made objects from space things like
dams Bridges and pyramids and at night
you can see a light show from the
world's big cities
and that's not all we're ready to bust
even more crazy space myths like the sun
being yellow and humans without a suit
exploding in space but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]